et pour en débattre nous sommes sur ce
plateau à paris avec palau in président
de république n things french merci
merci d'être avec nous en duplex jean
eric branaa chercheur à l'iris
spécialiste des états unis merci à vous
aussi merci d'être en direct par skype
avec nous à leur première étape très
attendue des primaires démocrates le
scrutin je me vois déjà avec le gros
sourire par le rythme vous avez dû bien
romar excusez moi de l'expression mais
alors qui tourne au fiasco a dû
être un grand moment de bonheur pour
vous c'est une fiasco c'est une fille à
ce que c'est oui évidemment fous rires
il faut c'est juste un crime qu'il n'a
pas encore un résultat est il annoncé
ils ont annoncé qu'il y aura cinq en
prison je crois que cinq ans pour faire
d'eux des résultats de total
ce soir et j'ai vu que même les colzas
annoncé ça il y avait des candidats qui
a dit on en entend plus en rien parce
que 150 essences r ça c'est rien taxez
moi j'aimerais dire que c'est typique
pour s'être pâtir un peu désastre en ce
moment mais je crois que c'est le début
d'une semaine très difficile pour les
démocrates aujourd'hui c'était à ce qu
un maillot ce soir c'est le discours sur
l'état de l'union
c'est pas président de chambre l'état de
l'union et est très fort on va en parler
juste brillant dans sa vie à tenter
demain ce discours est évidemment de la
campagne mais on va quand même s'arrêter
sur ce fiasco incroyable c'est vrai
qu'on a du mal à y croire
jean eric branaa pour vous ça va peser
lourd c'est sûr que c'est comme si on
trébuche en partant d'un sprint 1 au 100
m 1 500 m un marathon je dirais même ça
va être compliqué de se sortir de ce pas
pour les démocrates ont finalement bon
la campagne va suivre son cours on va
oublier tout ça alors trois choses
d'abord oui je suis d'accord avec vous
c'est exactement comme si on se prenait
les pieds dans le tapis au moment de
démarrer une course de fond et et quand
ses chronos sur la libye c'est vraiment
là je rejoins paul un fiasco c'est c'est
parce qu'il fallait avoir pour lancer
une campagne puisque le caucus de l'iowa
normalement lance la dynamique de toute
la campagne et on peut le dire en
regardant ça mon dieu ça va être
compliqué mais le deuxième point
j'ai envie de dire à apple on le taquine
en feront parce qu'on se connaît que
après tout les démocrates ne font que ce
que les républicains ont fait avant eux
on se souvient du même caucus dans le
même maillot à en 2012 c'était les
républicains à ce moment là qui se
prenaient eux le les pieds dans le tapis
avec des problèmes de comptage des votes
qui n'était pas au rendez-vous et
finalement il y avait eu là une grosse
pagaille aussi en réalité c'est vrai que
c'est caucus sont toujours soumis à
beaucoup de panique et le troisième
point est ce que ça va avoir des
conséquences est bien évidemment que non
dès demain ce sera oublié
comme toutes les nouvelles aux états
unis actuellement mais il faut dire
qu'on a un président le président que
que paul défend aujourd'hui avec tant de
force qui nous fait le show trois fois
par jour et en faisant le show trois
fois par jour il
il repousse ses nouvelles qui l'embêtent
mais il repousse aussi les nouvelles qui
ont fait les démocrates ce qui fait que
en vraie vérité on va très vite repartir
dans cette campagne
dès la semaine prochaine et un nouveau
vote dans le new hampshire on regardera
ça avec des yeux vraiment très différent
mais c'est vrai que pour le départ c'est
ça donne un côté papa terrible enfin
pour la capacité des démocrates à
organiser un grand événement comme il y
aurait dû avoir normalement hier soir
pas loin système de plus
est ce que finalement est voué à
disparaître
est-ce que c'est pas le grand perdant de
ce vote hier ce système de caucus opus
wii n'est pas très fort et je n'ai pas
très bien en 3d la régie si on peut être
unique branagh je ne peux rater un monde
jeune john rich exactement
on veut bien enlever ça voilà merci et
puis augmenter le son oui oui tout à
fait est-ce que c'est pas le grand
perdant justement de ce vote
est ce que est ce qu'il est viable ce
système si tu les spectacles comprend
comprennent le système des élections
souhaitées les primaires c'est assez
compliqué chaque état peut décider le
propre système est normalement c'est une
vente normal comme dans une élection
générale
une vote électronique mais si c'est un
caucus c'est dans quelques états comme
highway s'est vu tout ça de vieux
tradition où tout le monde doit être
présents pour voter et pas dans un
endroit mais plus en droit et après ils
séparent entente de différents groupes à
qui ce qui se situe entre ces deux ce
qui soutient howard et après ils
discutent entre eux et après un vote il
lève la main et complémente c'est assez
manywa mais voilà c'était pas vous êtes
la nuit ils ont habité cette application
il ya qui a fait tuer un total de tuner
vos manuels et ça n'a pas marché
jean-yves brin naïve et contre la
tradition est manifestement la modernité
ne vont pas ensemble on aurait peut-être
dû rester sur la main levée avec ses
petits ces petits papiers commencent
explique ça en 2020 que ça fonctionne
aussi mal on dit toujours les
l'ingérence qu'on sait pas l'ingérence
et ce sont les bac technique fait ça on
s'estime pas en réalité un gc serristes
un bac technique c'est une synchro raté
il faut le dire ce bazar sans nom qui
appuient avoir d'ailleurs le nevada qui
va faire un caucus d'ordre dans quinze
jours a déjà annoncé qu'il n'utiliserait
pas cette application qui avait été
préconisée pour tous les cocus cette
fois ci donc on met tout ça au panier en
oublie et on passe effectivement à
l'ancienne méthode qui avec ses gros
défauts parce qu'il en avait aussi et
quand même quelque chose qui fonctionne
lui
justement côté de certains électeurs qui
ont effectivement rencontré des
difficultés pour voter c'est eux qui en
parle le mieux de la faculté que j'ai
rencontré a été la dernière étape dans
l'application lorsque je devais
soumettre la photo que la feuille de
calcul du caucus mais ils ont des traces
écrites dont tout devrait être en ordre
je crois que cela peut être ajouter de
la confusion
mais vous savez il ya une traçabilité la
traçabilité je crois que c'était basé
sur ce que l'on dit hier soir des gens
qui ont participé à tout cela par le
passé et cela fonctionne mieux avec des
pancartes
une fois que les groupes reconnus sont
placés dans la salle c'est tout ne passe
pas son temps à se déplacer les gens
sont donc posées c'est plus facile de
faire le décompte
et puis l'application vous savez c'est
juste un logiciel est ce que le système
de primaire jean eric branaa vos semble
encore via dans ces conditions puisque
vous parlez vous même
voilà de ce bug qui a eu lieu pour les
républicains aussi avant les démocrates
on peut toujours en continuer à
fonctionner à fond avec les primeurs en
général voulait dire avec un caucus
parce que comprenons qu aux etats unis
on a plusieurs systèmes qui se
superposent qu'on appelle primaire en
réalité on a les caucus et les primaires
les primaires elle même se divise entre
primaires ouvertes primaires fermées et
même primaire semi ouvertes ou fermées
comme ce sera le cas dans le new
hampshire envoyer si on voulait rentrer
dans la halle l'explication de tout le
système où on va y passer toute
l'émission
en tout cas il ya un gagnant c'est pas
ni bernie sanders ni pitt ne dit pas si
je le dis bien avec l'accent
d'accord il ya un grand gagnant c'est
donald trump
ce soir s'en sort grandie paris nous
n'allez pas me dire le contraire
non je ne vais pas dire le contraire
mais c'est vrai mais j'ai entendu que
bruni a bien fait et payne n'a pas très
bien fait seulement les bruits même si
on est trop tard exact je crois que ça
vient de leconte campagne du vernissage
mais les sondages avant qui a avancé à
avant de l'expérience et des grenouilles
en c1 2 en tête
binder deuxième à bridge et one ou un
maintenant n'était pas très fort et si
on veut si on reçoit des résultats un
jour peut-être on verra ce que bein n'a
pas très bien fait donc c'est sais c'est
pas supprimée pour nous parce qu'ils ont
cru que bahreïn n'étaient jamais une
très très fort candidat
on y à beaucoup plus d'enthousiasmé avec
des matraques que pai
parce que les les républicains comme
elle depuis le début de la campagne ont
envie que bernie sanders soit élu et il
ya une explication à cela c'est que si
bernie somme de se retrouver avec
l'investiture démocrate
ça permettrait à donald trump de
dérouler la campagne qu'il a lancée au
discours de l'union dernier d'ailleurs
c'était ce jour là qu'il est inaugurée
contre le socialisme et le communisme
qui met dans le dans le même sac
parce que bien entendu candidat modéré
que ce soit ben hayden claude michon ou
beauté djedj l'on mettrait beaucoup plus
on lui prenant le centre donc c'est ça
amusant que paul répète aujourd'hui les
mêmes arguments pendant temps à peu près
partout de la part du parti républicain
quel est selon vous le candidat qui
serait le plus à même de battre
donald trump fait un effort je sais que
ça va être dur pour vous d'avouer qu'il
y en a peut-être mais en toile
joe biden par exemple lombaire par
exemple non non comme j'ai dit je crois
que le démocrate qui a un peu
d'enthousiasmé comme chante même pas le
même enthousiasme que ceux qui
soutiennent tandja mais au moins bien
un troisième appareil il n'a pas
beaucoup deuxième et y avait dans tous
les sondages de l'établissement médias
est situé lui enquête mais si on voit
c'est c'est réalisé c'est confiance
il n'a pas beaucoup de gens mais pas
contre burnley inclusion c'est une vraie
1 13e
c'est authentique mais c'est
malheureusement c'est mal comment on
peut dire comme john gnl qui a dit que
malheureusement c'est les jeunes pour
que des gens qui selon nous seule
républicaine c'est les jeunes qui
étaient avec lavage de cerveau ne ferez
pas le professeur et il croit que
socialisme est mieux que capitalisme que
capables de capitalisme c'est mauvais et
même qu'ils ont étudié un peu
d'enthousiasmé face à jamais assez pour
convaincre le plupart des américains de
votre socialisme
une réponse à peine bin oui on se
connaît bien avec paul donc on sait
chacun ce que pense l'autre mais en
réalité moi je pense que dans cette
campagne joe biden garde toutes ses
chances alors qu'yves qui le qui gagnent
ou qu'ils perdent dans le l'iowa puisque
pour elle expliqué tout à l'heure que
baye donne sur un très mauvais résultat
et c'est certainement vrai d'ailleurs
d'après ce qu'on entend j'ai les mêmes
prix que lui en réalité ça n'a aucune
importance puisqu'il ya 40 délégués à
distribuer entre cinq candidats qui vont
avoir gagné ils vont avoir gagné parce
qu'ils auront des délégués et ils vont
ce donc se divise et chacun sait
déléguer si vous divisez 40 par par cinq
voiliers il n'y a pas beaucoup de
délégués pour chacun peut être 10 12
pour les gagnants et 5,6 pour les
perdants la différence est vraiment très
très faibles alors
il faut gagner que 3900 candidats sur
l'ensemble donc que celui qui a gagné
qui a perdu ne va pas avoir gagné ou
perdu grâce à la you are ça n'a vraiment
aucune importance et joe biden reste
toujours celui qui est capable
aujourd'hui d'avoir l'investiture parce
que une fois qu'il aura passé des deux
premiers écueils que son l'iowa le new
hampshire
il va se trouver avec le nevada et la
caroline du sud où il est donné gagnant
très en avance et derrière surtout il ya
ce qu'on appelle le super mardi où là il
devrait rafler la mise et certainement
être très loin devant ensuite par
rapport à tous les candidats
peut-être bernie sanders va réussir à
s'accrocher mais ce sera vraiment le
seul vraiment vous fait pas peur il ne
pas les qualités requises pour être à la
hauteur
il représente l'établissement des
démocrates est probablement est là mais
c'est au minimum moitié des démocrates
probablement plus c'est une question de
combien est-ce qu'il ya un pourcentage
critiques de ceux qui soutiennent ces 1
2 est ce que c'est ce qu'ils
représentaient 50% c'est moins de 50%
ont mon avis c'est moins de 50%
donc il y aura toujours ce grand
établissement qui cherche un candidat
taximan qui bike bagne commence de
tomber en fait c'est pas très bien il y
aura moins ou peut être
il va chercher quelqu'un bloomberg et
bloomberg justement il faut fait pas
peur non non et une offre il n'y a pas
un candidat
démocrate qui offre les vraies solutions
pour états unis poule c très divisée
c'est très divisés c'est vrai mais il y
avait un mouvement de gauche à droite
pas un mouvement de droite à gauche aux
états non mais paul quand même dire
qu'elle est clair quand même qu'abidal
il est républicain compatibles il est le
candidat qui peut être accepté par les
républicains que que du côté de republic
and the world on appellerait rhino
certainement en tout cas de ceux qui
sont à la marge de ce parti républicain
qui étaient proches de bush cocker flex
et ryan et c'est ceux là sont toujours
séduit par quelqu'un comme comme vahid
et byden séduit aussi les plus anciens
il faut pas oublier que donald trump a
été élu par ses plus anciens c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça qu'il a battu quatre
cruz je crois d'ailleurs que paul
soupçonné d'être cool si je me souviens
bien il ya quatre ans et la différence
elle s'est faite à partir du new
hampshire au moment où les plus anciens
ont voté justement qui ont mis donald
trump en avant c'est là que ça devient
difficile pour donald 36 se trouve face
à un candidat qui va être exactement sur
ses potes mais et a beaucoup des gens
comme moi qui a voté pour un autre
candidat dans les primaires
républicaines qui maintenant sont 100%
derrière trompe pas ce que font pas
montre et a montré tous les américains
il fait des résultats ces politiques
fait les bons résultats donc c'est moins
des gens comme ça le public plus de 95%
la carto n'était pas une attaque de ma
part c'était pour dire que donald trump
avait été chercher des électeurs que
t'être cause n'était pas capable de
garder notamment les plus anciens mais
ces électeurs-là aujourd'hui ils peuvent
être séduits par joe biden parce que
justement il récupère également
l'électorat le plus âgé
peut-être un peu vous dites vous dites
voilà ils ont été séduits ses électeurs
par par la politique les résultats de
donald trump vous parlez au niveau
national les résultats économiques
c'est sur cela que va se jouer
clairement là la présidentielle aux
états unis clairement pour la plupart
des américains
ça c'est les choses on a quand même le
mérite l'économie en premier en premier
un sur l'économie je fais très bien
trempa a promis 3 millions pour nous
verrons ce travail et il a créé plus de
7 millions le taux de chômage est le
plus bas depuis 50 ans et surtout pour
les mineurs et les minorités les
informant qu'un pour les latino
américains pour les asiatiques et les
femmes le taux de chômage c'est
incroyable et quand c'est très très bas
et qu'on est grâce à ça les salaires
montent et a même plus il ya plus des
postes de travail ouverts que les gens
qui cherchent et ça montre le salaire et
donc les gens sont contents et ça c'est
pourquoi rien mouvement que le milieu
parle pas des insultes une minorité qui
a voté démocrate avant qu'ils sont dans
le parti républicain
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils voient que les
résultats d'études vraiment un fait du
bien jean eric branaa c'est extrêmement
intéressant ce que nous dit pas green
parce que c'est vrai qu'on on n'y pas
beaucoup ça effectivement il faut bien
le dire dans les médias occidentaux
qu'est ce que vous répondez vous le
spécialiste des états unis à ces
arguments assez implacable à et du bien
cela compter sur la politique économique
avec eux deux les résultats dans ce
domaine de donald trump sont excellents
selon par laurine avait si vous lisiez
pas c'est qu'on n'avait pas lu mais
arctique où mes bouquins parce que je
l'écris dedans je dis la même chose que
paul jeudi que l'économie fonctionne
bien redit que et je vais plus loin que
lui
par exemple je dis que les réguler la
nar et des régulations à booster
l'économie que le la baisse des impôts
est un élément très important de la
réussite donald trump qui arrive
effectivement à ces résultats
avec une croissance qui est arrivé à
troyes à deux reprises l'année dernière
2 2 sur l'année une inflation qui est
qui et maîtriser un chômage qui
effectivement est descendu à 3 5 et qui
devrait même descendre encore cette
année mais c'est pas là dessus que ça va
se jouer et comment est-ce qu'on peut le
dire tout simplement parce que les
américains disent déjà qu'ils sont
contents de l'économie ils le disent
même à certaines périodes de l'année ils
l'ont dit jusqu'à 65%
nous sommes satisfaits de ce que fait
donald trump sur l'économie mais quand
on regarde la popularité ne bouge pas
elle est toujours aujourd'hui au nom opa
sur rcp ce qui est un intégrateur elle
est à 44 9
ça n'a pas changé il est monté jusqu'à
45 mais c'est vraiment le maximum qu'il
a réussi à faire alors on peut être
satisfait de l'économie et de la
politique économique donald train et ne
plus vouloir donald trump comme
président c'est c'est là dessus je crois
que ça va se jouer pourquoi parce qu'il
ya une société divisée avec des clivages
qui se joue sur des valeurs et les
valeurs de certains de la majorité ne
sont pas celles de leur président c'est
là le gros problème alors donald trump
va essayer de nous la jouer à partir de
ce soir avec le discours de l'union en
se rendant présidentiable s'il se tient
à une stature présidentielle bleus et
présidentielle jusqu'à la fin de l'année
je crois qu'il a une vraie chance d'être
réélu
mais est-ce qu'il va tenir parce que le
meilleur ennemi donald trump ça reste
quand même donald trump qui n'avaient
pas forcément ça va se jouer selon jean
eric branaa sur les valeurs et il faut
vraiment qu'ils fassent un effort de
voilà d'être présidentiables de se
conduire comme tel vous attendez
beaucoup justement de ce discours de
l'union ce soit super discours surtout
devant tous les démocrates qui
voudraient destituer son président est
le vôtre sera demain plus aucun raison
d'appeler leur a pesé sur la campagne
mais non déjà le majorité des
délinquants a vu cette procédé
destitution pour absurdité que
mais j'en arrive chez vous lui de
répondre à un point il va parler de le
populaire était le sondage de popularité
il a ils ont ri que c'est à 44 % qu'en
cas 45 mais en fait ça montait un peu
avant c'était dans 38 40 ça manquait un
petit et qui fait des bons résultats
économiques nouvelles explique voir
parce que c'est le timing très divisé et
mais je voudrais vous dire que en sept
points
ce même moment trois ans après
l'élection d'obama en 2008 sont pas pu
l'arrêter c'est été - quelque 1 400 donc
de popularité de la bande
obama a descendu pendant le premier
trois ans et c'était 4 43% et chante
mieux qu'obama le même temps dans ce
monde premier mandat donc sept sondages
de popularité c'est pas très important
ainsi le résultat qu'il a fait le fait
que le parti démocrate est très motivé
il ya beaucoup enthousiasme on peut voir
dans les dents les rails du train des
notions qu'il fait à agua il ya toujours
cette 10 millions et non de digne en
ligne en dehors et les gens ils sont on
apparaît dans les politiques des
intérieurs qui est important pratique
extérieure
les résultats sont très positives aussi
et des chaussons pas plus d'un dess on
parle plus des problèmes de
son sac on parle plus d'elle même c'est
un oui c'est une pratique tranchant qui
a détruit des tâches en syrie et en irak
joyent brad a réussi et des autres mais
surtout pas les politiques de danger et
you pays après a tué le chef de l'état
ils ont mis qu il a tué le chef des
problèmes intériste de diront on parle
plus d'eux le problème durant dans un
corps de déesse commun ou bien sûr tâche
ne sera jamais éliminé que samson % mais
il faut dire que les américains se
désengage de série quand même oui oui
mais avant ça par exemple si on fait
beaucoup dé bon chose c'est mon point
alors un sérieux et extérieur on va
aller on va laisser le mot de la fin
très rapidement si nous payons à
l'iguana idée déjà 56 et on a un nouveau
journal à 22h s'il vous plaît rapidement
les conclusions
non c'était intéressant parce que paul
nous a fait à peu près le discours qui
va être tenu par donald trump ce soir
dans discours de l'union l'était mais
elles sont déjà là c'est l'économie ses
épaules ne l'a pas parler l'immigration
et c'est la politique extérieure ça va
être les trois points qui vont être
développés mais en remettant
l'immigration ce soir parce que je crois
que c'est ce que va faire donald trump
il va encore jouer sur la polarisation
c'est là dessus que je pense qu'ils
aient commis une erreur et qui va
entraîner sa perte
parce que contrairement à ce que disait
paul en tout cas j'ai une vraie
divergence avec lui là dessus je crois
que sa popularité ne peut pas monter au
dessus 45%
elle est bloquée parce qu en poussant
sur ces thèmes qui qui fixe sa base
autour de lui et qu'il a solidifie et b
il empêche en même temps de l'éclatement
vers le centre en tout cas
l'élargissement de cette base merci bon
point koné de par image en libres 1 1
pour ce débat nourri la fin